hi this is pressure Locker and today I'm
going to explain the rule of 72 which is
a formula for how fast your investment
will double the formula is that 72
divided by the rate of return is the
time for your investment to double we
can go through some examples let's say
your rate of return is 3% and you want
to know how long it takes to double the
rule of 72 says if you take 72 divided
by 3 the answer is 24 so investing at 3%
will take about 24 years to double if
you have a rate of return of 4% we can
take 72 divided by 4 and that gives us
18 years
other examples are with the rate of
return of 6% it'll take you 12 years
with 8% it'll take you nine years and
with 12% it'll take you 6 years for your
investment to double while the rule of
72 is very popular there's important
important things to remember first of
all it's an approximate formula and
although it's accurate
it is still an approximation it's only
going to work for returns between about
4% and 18% and most importantly the rule
of 72 will not work if you keep
investing every month or every year and
it also requires a constant return every
year so if you have a return of 10% one
year 5% another year you know negative
3% another year the rule of 72 is not a
good guide it has to work with the
constant return so it annoys me to no
end the rule of 72 is always mentioned
by investment advisers and fine
enchiladas analyst and it's simply not
suitable for investing in the stock
market so my bit of advice is if you
ever meet with someone who tries to
manage your money and they tell you
about the rule of 72 just walk out
because it does not work the stock
market has unpredictable returns that
change every year so why does the rule
of 72 even work it has to do with the
formula for compound interest if you
invest P dollars at a rate of annual
rate of return of are 40 years the
amount of money you'll end up with is P
times 1 plus R to the T what we want to
do is we want to say how long will it
take for the money to double so we now
have an equation that says if you invest
P we want to solve for the time T that
you'll end up with to P so the first
thing we'll do is we'll cancel out the
peas from here we'll take the natural
log of both sides and we're almost done
we have a linear equation in T and we're
almost at the rule 72 so we'll need a
couple of approximations first of all
the natural log of 2 is about 70% and we
will round that to 72 percent because 72
has a lot more divisors the other trick
is that the natural log of 1 plus R is
approximately equal to R when R is
between 4 and 18% so if R is 5% the
natural log of 1 plus 5% is about 5%
so using these approximations we have
the T times R is 72 and that means the
time to double is equal to 72 divided by
the rate of return and that's the
derivation for the rule of 72 I hope you
enjoyed this video please subscribe to
my channel you can catch me on my blog
bind your decisions
or on Twitter at pressure Locker